Hundreds of skateboarders are expected to gather tomorrow...
...in support of Black-led skate clubs across the city.
It's called Skate for Solidarity.
Tomorrow is a Skate for Solidarity.
So, as skateboarders,...
...we do feel a responsibility to look out for each other.
Skate parks act as a crime deterrent...
...because skateboarders are eyes on the street constantly.
And so what that means for us is that we make sure...
... that whenever injustices are happening,...
...whether it's within our own skate parks...
...or an abuse of power, we're always looking out for each other...
...and making sure that one another are safe...
So, this action tomorrow is a representation of that,...
...of what we do and the advocacy that we represent...
...in this city and in our skate parks.
We really thought it'd be a great thing to do...
...and we saw that change needed to happen.
And this was a perfect opportunity to kind of jump on that...
...and make a change in the world and do a good thing.
I think the skateboarding community is like really...
...we're all really accepting...
...but still, in the skateboarding community, there is racism.
It's not as bold as some other places but it's definitely there.
And I think that just having the whole skateboarding community coming together...
...would be a really great thing.
And be influenced to kind of also donate....
...to the different initiatives that we're doing, to Oldowan Blackboard...
...and they're also trying to support skaters...
...who might not have the opportunity...
...to be sponsored and they're giving them that opportunity...
...to be able to skateboard like the rest of us.
And I think that's really awesome....
...and it's just something that everyone deserves.